[موسيقى]
هنا في المركز الاعلامي للانتخابات انطلقت
عمليه التحضير للدور الثاني من التشريعيات
المبكره التي ستدور نهايه الشهر الحاليه
هيئه الانتخابات تعلن انها على اتم
الاستعداد لانجاح هذا الاستحقاق رغم كل
التعديلات حاولنا انه نضع
الانتخابات التشريعيه
الرئيس سعيد يؤكد مره اخرى انه لا مجال
للعوده الى الوراء ويصدر مرسوم لدعوه
الناخبين للتوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع امر
اربك قيادات النهضه التي فشلت مره اخرى
بدورها في تحريك الشارع قطار 25 مواصل
والخارطه السياسيه مواصله للدور الثاني في
الانتخابات التشري التشريعيه وده يعني هو
مسار 25 فيديو هو اللي يمسح يعني منظومه
الزمن والانتخابي يوازيه اخر قضائيه
في النهضه بتهمه تدليس جوازات سفر تونسيه
وتسليمها لعناصر ارهابيه قضيه اخرى من
القضايا المتورطه فيها قيادات النهضه
تنضاف الى قضايا الفساد والاغتيالات
والارهاب وتبييض الاموال
الماكينه التي صنعتها حركه النهضه داخل
المؤسسات التي تحاول ان تعطل اليوم ما
يربها هي ان هذه القدره على حمايه وتغطيه
كل هذه القضايا انتهت وبالتالي اصبح
مكشوفين ما يرعبهم هو كشف الحقائق
وسيتم تركيزه البرلمان الجديد بدايه شهر
مارس اغار المقبل ومن اوكد اولوياته النظر
في قانون تمويل الاحزاب والجمعيات لا شيء
يوقفوا قتال تغيير المشهد السياسيه
التونسي واستكمال مشروع الرئيس سعيد عبر
تركيز البرلم جديد واغلاق فتره حكم
الاخوان الذين صاروا يواجهون اسواق زوبعه
قضائيه وسياسيه عاصفه بوجود هم في البلاد
وفقا مراقبهم وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس